talk about what's going on with the
vaccine
should people be concerned about one
being better than the other
no they're exactly the same in terms of
the outcome you know take whichever you
can get first if it's your turn to get
vaccinated
pfizer or moderna both excellent
vaccines they say
if you get one shot then you have 60
immunity what does that exactly mean so
what it means is 60
of your total immunity as if you have
gotten two shots and so what we know is
that by day 10 after the first shot
you start to have some protection and
that protection
it'll down modulate your response so you
may get a bad cold but you're not going
to end up in the hospital or end up on a
ventilator and that's what we care about
in the long run
is the covid adjusting now to this cure
that we have
and sort of coming up with superpowers
to
fight our vaccine or or will we be
protected if we get the vaccine
we are going to have and i know people
don't want to hear this but this was
expected and i don't think it's that bad
of news
is that at some point we're going to
give you a second vaccine with a little
bit different spike protein to cover the
the new strains
and then a year later just like the flu
shot you'll get slightly other variants
and they're going to be tiny changes in
the spike protein in addition to the
other spike protein we're getting now so
you'll get a mix of spike proteins which
will give you immunity to all the
strains but we will win against this
virus
we will knock it down science is coming
through the idea of getting back to
normal
by normal i mean hey i want to go to a
movie or i want to go to a restaurant i
wanted
it's going to take time sometime around
june or july
we should be getting towards 75 to 80
percent of the country vaccinated which
will get us to hurt immunity
a month or two after that um if we all
keep wearing the mask the virus numbers
will go
down dramatically in the country and we
can go back to what we call a new normal
which is wearing masculinity when we're
sick
more interactions going out of our house
etc
at the same time we're going to have
what we call molecular surveillance
across the country
looking for little outbreaks of the
virus and if that happens we're going to
get boosters
but we're going to be back to a new
normal i promise you
this is not going to be the way of life
we're going to be able to see
everybody's expressions and see people
smile
i'm going to be able to hug robin and
all of those things that we want to do
will happen
we first have to convince everyone to
get the vaccine
what do you say to these people who are
listening right now who say i'm not
getting that vaccine
so first of all go to the back of the
line we have enough people in the
country who want it over the next couple
of months that'll take up all the supply
if you don't want it i'll make the
argument later i want the people who
understand the science and step up to
get that vaccine now you have companies
like live nation the biggest concert
provider in the country
who said we're going to put on concerts
in the future but you're going to need a
certificate that you had a vaccine to
attend
so when you look at the data we didn't
rush this vaccine this reflected the
fact that
science got pretty good over the last
couple decades and we can make things
quicker and better than we ever could
before and then when you look at the
safety i mean it's unparalleled
there has been no serious adverse event
that has lasted in
millions of people being vaccinated
across the country
this is pretty cool so remarkably safe
and it works it stops 100
hospitalization and death
from the virus i don't see how it could
be any better i think these people they
think the vaccine is going to affect
their health somehow they're going to go
blind or you know some weird thing
if you look historically with every
vaccine we've done the side effects are
all seen in the first month or so we
don't see other side effects the vaccine
is gone
your immune response happened so we
don't see side effects that happen at
six months and a year down the road
they all are in the near term and we
haven't seen them and that's really
exciting the counter is the virus
this little thing behind my shoulder is
a nasty devil
even if you're asymptomatic no symptoms
at all
you know twenty thirty percent of people
could have inflammation of the heart
seventy eighty percent can have
inflammation of the lung and those who
cause health problems the rest of your
life
so we have to do what we can to stop
this virus well i'm really glad i had
you on the show today dr agus
and if there's anybody who was sort of
on the fence about getting the vaccine i
think after hearing what you have to say
this is going to go a long way and i'm
going to close out uh i think i'm going
to play the doctor against theme song
what do you think of that
dr eggs let us all dance together now as
we listen to
vegas yeah